to polite when you had to say about I
listen listen you on below the belt
I like we had to say about bless and is
the third fight is appropriate yeah give
me a third fight he's earned it he's a
legend man give him a third fight is
only twenty eight like the division
can't just move on you know I'm saying
can't just move on from that I bet if
you asked Alexander Vulcan Asti he's
gonna say the same thing like yeah I
would like a clear-cut win before I
[ __ ] move on yeah there's they're
saying that pay-per-view trended towards
1.2 million buys by the way Jesus fine
island the real deal is amazing but what
what helps is what really helps is a guy
like my husband oh yeah man he's a draw
I love I just can't get enough you know
I think I think it out smiles at all I
think it helps loose man I think it
helps max out it helps everybody do you
think Maz be da are you very treat by a
rematch or do you think the same thing
happens with all due respect I don't
even give immediate rematches too many
guys waiting in the wings I think right
I think yes to me I think you fight coat
it'd be smarter for Mozilla fight Colby
anyways cuz just make your money man
you're getting real money so fight Colby
it's a good matchup for you let loose
men take out Gilbert or Leon Edwards
which is a risk but you know you are you
more worried about Leon Edwards than you
are about Gilbert yeah yes really like a
gilbert seems like a [ __ ] explosive
monster we've been fighting for a long
time beat he's just under you know he's
on the surge right now but Leon Edwards
a real deal man you know there's a
[ __ ] problem
he's won eight in the road but God he
just he doesn't get enough credit
because you know he's over in the UK to
can't do [ __ ] yeah that's true that's
true
yeah thank God there's fights tonight
something to do and Saturday and
Saturday
who's fighting Saturday Saturday's Joey
Benavidez you got big-ass limb fighting
there none of the cards are like stacked
especially like that people for to fight
nights on a Wednesday and a Saturday
sign me
I'll take it I can't believe that baby
did 1.2 million in this in this current
climate we're gonna [ __ ] depression
that's insane dude it's insane that's
that's remarkable remarkable pretty cool
yeah it's great shows you maybe the
economy's about to back a little bit I
hope so the market I'll tell you this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]